hello and welcome to see you play I am
van Ostrand in a sloth I don't know who
is that no name of this getting rid of
this yeah they all know that nowadays
not be d 7 45 and there is no advantage
for white Kim I think I have to go for
some other line ok it's not playing this
main line this makes it a bit more
interesting at least yeah I probably
have to think of something else in this
opening as I said this is not not the
real problem there's something else
the media t5 assistance is another it's
more of an issue at the moment anyway
let's just play this game canceled i
played this rather quickly the last
couple of moves because to be honest i
don't know it anyway so there is nothing
that I can you know sometimes you you
you kind of try to recall the particular
line that you know why anything like
that in this case I don't know a line so
I just played some quick moves hoping
hoping for the best in a way can I try
to get denied over here to f5 it's often
the the key IDM or one key IDM okay so
let's go back night shift takes Knight
takes the night is ready to jump to have
five Arab the eight is probably probably
very decent move yeah yeah Black is fine
him definitely push your age three is
mostly to connect rooks
okay so they decided to take this gives
me those night f5 ideas even though it's
not clear that this is helping helping
that much yeah I think I'm still going
to to do that and now maybe here try to
play a for later hardly he's covering
this but I might have some Quincy 1 + f4
Jem I know maybe this is equal my F for
weakness my bishop on a tree added it
don't look so great but maybe I still
have ideas to get an F form Queen c1f
for something like that and at least I
was quicker I mean I'm a hat on the
clock so what now is this Quincy one an
idea I mean okay if I get an F for I
don't really know what I'm when I'm
gaining with this to be perfectly honest
okay I saw you shoot for that yeah I
didn't quite see if this is so helpful
maybe it is maybe it is yeah yeah Black
is fine I'd rather be black in this
position no question them
let's reboot this
53 c 2 and then maybe f4 this is my idea
reorganizing the position a little bit
roop the eight probably it's not the
easier to move to to play rook t1 I
would love to play with don't don't see
this at the moment how that would work
there should be two blunders f2 not easy
d this one for b3 trying to kick him
back currently the d7 night it's not so
great which is they did sound f6 night
that's what I'm trying to say
God through teacher on the corner what
do what are you doing to me here
if I go III here and winning a piece
right but it's a damn em strange still
will be very tricky to play the
pollution my king is just not safe at
all oh BTW just not on i'm looking at
this a case time morning I had so very
uncomfortable to play the position with
my wide open position here the King 22
is down check check
check
check objectively I'm okay I think but
it's so damn tricky check check check
check okay so it's a draw maybe I could
have done something time-wise around but
I was sore thumb somewhat happy to draw
this I really got got into huge trouble
down so yeah I know it it felt felt like
having trouble maybe it's not that bad I
don't know i came i hear the computer
actually believes that four is good for
me around here I felt like I'm in some
trouble and 83 okay maybe he had this
when I'm just about holding according to
the engine and I am done drawing this
yeah I might try to win
oh well now again but this is still
super super annoying in the in the time
pressure 23 is a lot stronger though
oops sorry it should check was check
this is what the engine is giving and
gives me a pretty substantial advantage
yeah I'm absolutely i'm totally sure
that a computer would win this with
white but with a with a good bday human
player it's so difficult check here I
was trying happy to have some
coordination and jack yeah this is
certainly difficult to play for windows
why no it's got tons of pawns oops sorry
it's got tons of porn switch I will
start to pick some up I think draw is
very it's a very likely outcome check
check I was surprised that you went to
the end game which this might be lost
with best play um but for black i mean
but i'm not i'm not sure probably not
not oh sorry i cannot be lost sorry this
is a wrong wrong bishop no no no you
just have to get the F porn so he has a
draw basically in the back here sorry
yeah I think I'm okay with the draw it
was a tough game thanks for watching